good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name's John I work for the city folks at
a recent press conference at my home and
asked to all those in attendance my wife
the dog in the cab that was endorsing to
Senator Barack Obama good morning John
this is a special edition about the hood
juvenile I'm in the longest line of my
entire life without a doubt and actually
continues to go around this way and then
it goes back down there to where you can
see anymore and then it comes back and
then it goes back that way Adam and I
are gonna try and see Barack Obama this
morning we're waking up at seven o'clock
in the morning it's pretty much the most
that I can do for anyone in the world so
I'm obviously pretty picture
Obama was amazing as you might have
expected instead of showing you all lots
of clips from the whole thing because
that would take like an hour because
that how long his Pete was was amazing
no notes you just stood there and gave a
50-minute speech with jokes and like
improvisation but when I was watching a
video from yesterday on I noticed that
something sounded really familiar and
then I figured out what it was and so I
wanted to share that with you the weird
thing that those advertisements end up
doing is making you think that the poor
are in some way fundamentally different
from us that they're like of them get
all the reservation your Montana
that's not alone and so in our minds it
becomes this formulation we should help
them but it's not a Venn problem it's an
us problem
every child is our problem every child
is our responsibility we need to help us
yeah yeah yeah my brother and Barack
Obama are both very made of Awesome I
even remember being taught in school
that that there was a hierarchy of needs
and the people who didn't have the basic
needs like housing and food don't care
about the next levels on the hierarchy
which of good things like social status
in self-realization and all that crap
but that's totally not true that's the
hierarchy of needs was created by
someone who never had to deal with the
first need just because you don't have
food doesn't mean that you're some kind
of animals you don't care about other
people that you don't want to do good
things that you don't want to do good
things for yourself and for your
community it means that you can't do
those things it's so screwed up that
that I was taught that in school and
while you're like oh well they should
have food so they can achieve those new
levels it also makes you think that
maybe it's not such a big deal if they
don't have food because they don't know
about the the further levels that they
could be achieving frankly I can't
believe that anybody ever said this but
the hierarchy of needs actually has two
levels before you get to love so people
who don't have enough food or shelter
and also according to the sky people who
don't have personal safety don't need
love or friendship or family they need
to give food and shelter and safety
before they want dignity and family and
community ah it's really no wonder we're
so good at ignoring these huge horrible
problems that our world has maybe it's
about a way to try and create a world
where people can live without feeling
extremely guilty every second of their
lives anyway how much does an Xbox 360
cost because if he could give that much
I could probably give that much so I'm
gonna check that out two hundred and
fifty dollars an Xbox 360 costs $250 and
here I go to Shawn's PayPal to 5-0
update total John thanks for being an
awesome person and awesome brother
I'll see you on
day